hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a problem from a 5th grade
chinese textbook
in the quadrilateral abcd
angle a is equal to 90 degrees
angle abd is equal to 40 degrees
angle bdc is equal to 5 degrees
angle c is equal to 45 degrees
and the length of a b is equal to 6.
the puzzle is to find the area of
quadrilateral abcd
i thank eric from miami for suggesting
this problem and for sending a solution
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
well i'm first going to present the long
way which is to solve with trigonometry
this is the way i would have solved the
problem
but it's actually not the way that
students would have been expected to
solve it because fifth graders would not
have learned trigonometry
so i'm going to show this method just to
show how you could solve it using
trigonometry
it's going to be rather complicated and
i'm going to go through it very quickly
and i'm just going to assume that you
can figure out all the trigonometric
steps along the way
so let's solve this and then we'll see
by comparison the correct method by
which they expected students to solve
the problem
so let's get started
first we'll solve that angle adb is
equal to 50 degrees
and then angle dbc is equal to 130
degrees
next we'll calculate that the length of
ad is equal to 6 times the tangent of 40
degrees
then the length of bd is equal to 6
divided by the cosine of 40 degrees
we can then use the law of sines to get
that cb is equal to 6 divided by the
cosine of 40 degrees
times the ratio the sine of 5 degrees
over the sine of 45 degrees
now that we've calculated some of these
values we can calculate the areas we
want
now triangle abd is a right triangle so
we can calculate its area as 6 times 6
times the tangent of 40 degrees all over
2.
we then need to calculate the area of
triangle cbd
to do that we use the formula for the
area of the triangle in which we know a
side an angle and a side
this formula is to multiply the length
of one side times the length of the
adjacent side times the sine of the
angle in between and you divide all of
that by two
so we substitute in the values we have
using side cb
bd
and the angle in between
so now
to get the area of the quadrilateral we
take the area of abd plus the area of
cbd
you can use a calculator to do this i
don't know how you would simplify it
otherwise
and you end up with the answer of 18.
wow
how does it all come down to 18
what's the trick
so here we go
the incredible trick is to flip triangle
cbd upside down
so we'll focus on triangle cbd
and now let's flip it upside down
now notice that angle adc is equal to 50
degrees plus 130 degrees which is equal
to 180 degrees which is a straight line
next angle abc is equal to 40 plus 5
which is 45 degrees
and then angle acb is equal to 45
degrees
so what we have now is that abc is an
isosceles right triangle
and the area we want will be the area of
this entire shape
so we can simplify this to be an
isosceles right triangle
one of its sides is six so the other
side is also equal to six
the area of this triangle will be its
base times its height divided by 2 which
is 6 times 6 divided by 2 and that's
equal to 18.
amazing
this is unlike any problem i've seen in
a math class competition or a test what
a neat simplification
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free inspire and build confidence for
people around the world and they already
have over a hundred million views
let's share the beauty of mathematics
with your help we can math the world a
better place
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos watch and share all of
mind your decisions videos
email me a puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
books which are linked in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support